a new children's book is tackling a very
serious issue for kids and their parents
it's called i love this title if you
touch i'll tell its goal is to protect
children from predators and teach them
to speak up for themselves the book is
written like a poem with verses like if
someone touches you you must tell and
fight and scratch and kick and yell
dr shamina obershan is the author of
this book she joins us now at the table
good morning to you good morning i've
been getting a lot of children's books
lately because of favorite grandson luca
this landed on my desk and first i
winced a little bit because i went oh
morning tv i don't know then i read it
and i thought that's the problem because
people went saying oh i don't know we
don't want to talk about it i was raised
with stranger danger yes but when you
read this what you realize and what all
the experts know it's not the strangers
most of the time who are hurting your
children right it's actually not the
strangers um looking at the statistics
we find out that 93
of cases juvenile cases that go in front
of law enforcement the children actually
report that they've been abused by
someone that they know someone within
their family
right and only about seven percent of
the children will say that they did not
know who did it but even within that
seven percent some of the children they
lie because they don't want to hurt a
family member and you know what i loved
about what you did in the book and verse
i won't read it although it's very good
uh you said they will tell you that it's
a game they will tell you it's our
secret they will tell you i will hurt
your family if you tell yes and you put
all this guilt on the child and your
thing the constant refrain is it is not
my fault and if you do i will tell i
will yell i will make sure you're off
the streets you want children to have
their own voice i do i do because i did
not always have a voice you know i was
also i'm a survivor of child abuse and
it happened by a close family member
and at the time i did not have a voice
i was seven years old when it started
and i finally found my voice at 14
and at 10 i wanted to tell but i just
did not know how to
go to my mom and say those words those
words do not come out of me yeah so when
i wrote this book i put myself back at
10 and everything i thought i needed i
put in that video
yes ma'am the age of the child obviously
makes a big difference here 10 is
different than 14 is different than
seven when you think about the younger
kids and you're reading them that book
how do you explain to them the
difference between appropriate and
inappropriate touching definitely that
is something that one i tell children i
want to tell children i said in this
book an inappropriate touch is any touch
that makes you feel uncomfortable so i
know that there are a lot of books out
there that talk about good touch versus
bad touch but i think we need to be very
careful because for example i tell my
daughter even though your hand is maybe
not a private thing but if you ask your
friend not to touch your hands and your
friend insists that is a bad touch
because you need to have your body
boundaries and your hand is personal
your mind is personal even in the book i
talk about
saying something negative to a child
that's you know that could be potential
inappropriate behavior for the child's
mind yeah and so yeah anything that's
not appropriate to you what's it's okay
with me might be okay with you so in an
appropriate touch is anything but it's
more than that social media because you
show a a model of a child you show the
body parts yes and you and you point out
this is
this is your protected space right and
you also give a list of people a teacher
a babysitter a nephew a cousin a mother
a father a sister or brother you really
lay it all out for the child to be able
to speak up on that exactly i thought
that um when i was 10 if i just had a
poster in my room right and then i had
and i would just hold my mother's hand
and say mommy
that and she would say what happened
there and i would tell her and then she
would say who did it and i would go
and you would have i could have saved
four years you know of my life but i had
to wait until i was strong enough to
find those words so i wanted the
children to have a tool
now um as gail mentioned there is a
hesitancy from parents it could be due
to past trauma it could just be due to
fear it could just be being
uncomfortable having real conversations
with your kids yes um often times we amp
ourselves up and we say okay i'm going
to have this conversation or heart start
racing and then we dial it back yes what
advice do you give to parents how do you
encourage them to ask these tough
questions
i would tell parents you know what
for people like me who've been through
abuse you know it's easy for folks to
tell you it happened so long ago just
forget about it
you know i'm almost 42 and i live with
it every day and sometimes when i see my
daughter i just think about what she
could potentially go through and that
alone parents should know that your
child is so worthy to be saved and
prevention is better than cure
especially in the case of sexual abuse
there is no cure for this yes you have
to deal with it
so worthy to be saved did you like that
nate i like that
gave me goosebumps and you said there
are three words that parents can use
that are even more important than i love
you and i couldn't figure out what what
what that is what is it i believe you
yes because there's love and belief you
have to love a child enough to believe
them right yeah and when my mother told
me that she believed me
it meant everything oh my god yeah
even today i get emotional because she
believed me well let me tell you the
illustrations are great the story is
great i've told favorite daughter kirby
about it first she said i don't know
then she said but you know what i would
want luca to yell and tell yes because
those are the kids they go after they go
after the quiet kids not the kids who
are yelling and telling right you've set
it up very nicely in this book
thank you dr shimino good job good job
if you touch i'll tell is now on sale
wherever you like to buy your books
you're watching cbs mornings we thank
you for that we'll be right back